[Musique]
J'ai passé 27 ans en prison pour un crime que je
n'ai pas commis et je suis ici juste pour
vous soutenir parce que nous
avons besoin de changement dans ce système, il doit
être égal, il doit être juste et juste
vous savez  et je suppose que vous savez que par ma
présence ici, ma voix apporte ce type de
soutien et euh, j'espère que nous pourrons atteindre
les législateurs
ici en ce moment, la preuve visuelle est
tellement plus précieuse que la
preuve juste dans le papier, vous savez
qui est tapé sur un morceau de papier et les
gens voient juste un visuel qui peut le voir
plus clairement qu'ils ne le pourraient s'il s'agissait de
quelque chose qu'ils avaient  à lire que certaines
personnes supposent que le Jersey Devil est
lgd ici aussi bon que le système du nouvel an,
j'ose dire que cet auto
te fout en l'air et ce que j'ai fait est faux
[Musique]